welcome back to PJ J Design This is PJ I
often find inspiration from the vintage
jewelry in this video I'm going to show
you how to custom this ring inspired by
vintage design with the cion right in
the middle bezel set on the side and
twisting bar decoration in between the
bezel set are you ready let's get
[Music]
started I recently found this uh website
Museum of jewry if you are looking for
inspiration there's a lot of a great
design from the past that you can look
into it and this ring is inspired by one
of the image here that I found in this
Museum of the jewelry and highly
recommend that you check out this
website before we started uh we need to
see if this ring is actually working
first of all I will recommend everybody
always St all the hole behind the fet
stone it's because
number one is easier to clean later on
and then your stone will look brighter
if you just doing the design for
rendering purpose you may want to draw
the hole bigger because that allow more
light to go through all of this is with
the bezel set and I would like to uh
specific Design This twisting element to
go in between so those are the focus
point for this video that's starting
from scratch we are going to starting at
front view and we're going to set it up
for ring size I'm going to set set it up
diameter for 16 mm and highly recommend
you set exactly ring size for the Finish
size uh some people ask me what if the
printing or casting shrinking and I will
say yes your printer my shrink
differently if your printer ring a lot
yes you need to compensate the
differences however when you polish it's
going to lose some material so pretty
much it will go back to whatever the
ring size is that's why I keep saying
say always make the ring size is the
finished ring size and to making a
circle or round cavion is pretty easy we
can just make making a sphere for
whatever size you're going to have and
then we simply just triming half so I'm
going to
draw a line just right in the half and
using that line to trim the bottom and
we can delete that line and this is
going to be only the single surface so
we can use the cap command and to make
it into the solid then we want to move
this to whatever how high you want it to
have for this
caban after that we need to make a seat
I'm coming into the front view and we're
going to draw the profile again this is
going to look like a rendering so I
wanted to draw to make sure it look like
whatever is going to be finished so I'm
going to use the straight line and to
draw some something like this really
close to the object and I wanted to do
something like this and we just need to
go straight and I want to actually doing
more than um what I need for the length
because we're going to trim it off later
and it will ensure that we have enough
room I'm going to stop it right there
and notice that this because is uh
snapping and snapping everywhere is kind
of weird so that's use the command
projector to C
plan and we want to delete the input so
it will be flattened back then we can
create some Arc over there snapping into
the end point end point and get
something like this all right so it will
look rounder nicer when you have it in
render and let's go ahead to join it
also May wanted to just moving this
point out a little bit so it doesn't
feel like it's cutting into the stone or
something like this as long as you have
this rounded a little bit it will look
nicer on the rendering and if you don't
want to have this Kink we can have you
move it down to smooth it out or
something like that okay so that is
first and if you like it to be taper for
whatever reason you can simply just
moving those two to move the profile but
I want like to have a straight first
okay so now we have this curve over
there we are going to creating the
surface by using the revolve since this
is a circle and hit zero and enter
moving up here for
360° and we will get this piece over
here the second things I wanted to do to
bring a stone in and you can download
the stone at the link below I will ask
you to sign up a newsleter then you get
a link to download the stone and we kind
of decided How high that you want on the
stone whether you want it to be like
like lower or higher whatever that
you're going to do once make sure the
color of the stone is not stick it out
once you're turning into this position
right in the middle okay all right let's
give it a try I'm going to have that
stone and then you can size to whatever
that you want and I'm going to use the
polar rate that's snapping to the zero
for the center and I'm just going to
guess for 10 piece and I also want to
record a history here and let's click
okay because I record a history if I
move it that everything else will follow
it I do need to have a little bit room
since we are going to do the bezel set
and this time it need to be flushed to
the surface so we do need some space if
you caving that much it will look really
weird once you you don't have um over at
this point because you don't have enough
room to hammer the metal uh to Against
The Stone so we're going to move it out
like that I think 10 will look nice over
there and see if you like the angle
maybe you want it to be more tilted like
this if that were for you it's it's
really up to you for what you like all
right so that's say this is the distance
that I like this is the distance in the
middle that is good for some sort of a
decoration and it's up to you how you
like to arrange yours I'm going to stop
tweaking here and for you to continue on
your part so what I like to do is I need
to creating a surface first we need to
create a curve on the top view and also
the side view and intersect them so
that's starting with the top view I'm
going to use the polygon star the number
of the number right here is the number
of the stone so I'm going to snaping uh
uh number side for 10 and snapping to
the
zero and have it coming down something
like this okay and of course we don't
want those point so we wanted to fit it
the corners for one and that's that's
just about right okay because we need to
have a little bit room there you may
want to have a equal size room in
between so I'm going to move this one up
just a little bit and the history will
carry the rest of them all right so the
top view we finish this curve on my
front view I need to know what kind of
curve that I have over there that's
using the arc that has a three point and
that's snapping to the Grid on this
point and this point and I want to
simply just moving up something about
here so this will be the arc and we can
adjust it if we don't like it in fact we
just need half of them so I'm going to
use the split with the point and I split
right in the middle over here and we
need to delete half of them all right so
with this curve I can make a surface out
of it that's creating this solid first
I'm going to have that solid extruded
Planet curv straight and over like this
and we are going to creating the surface
with that Arc and that's using the
revolve again snapping into the
zero for
360° and we have another surface there
as you can see now we have those we can
use this as a cutting object to trim
this extra so now on the top we can have
nice nice uh round surface there and
take a look on this now this piece and
my stone is too exposed so actually I
need to move it up I'm just going to
come back um to moving this one up just
a little bit make sure I cover the stone
and then I'm going to use the trim again
we're going to trim using this one to
trim off this all right so now it look
much better okay and then the second
thing is we're going to use this one to
trim off this one
so now I have two surface just need to
join them together now this will become
solid all right on the bottom we
actually don't need that long so I'm
going to pick up the bottom surface and
basically just moving up like here and
then I want them to be taper so look
nicer so I'm going to 3D scale it down
then we got something like this if you
look at the
rendering you're going to see this
really sharp edges that doesn't look too
nice we are going to fill it the edges
and for something really small maybe uh
mm and make sure chain age equal yes and
so that will select
everybody and let's give it a try I
think the f is a little bit too big so
maybe we just need half of them I'm
going to try 0.15 it's just for the
rendering it's going to look better and
make sure chain age is equal yes all
right it look better and let's take a
look on the render as well all right so
all the basic is done and let's go back
to the ghost View and we want to take a
look on the decoration that we're going
to have now right here that we have a
curve we can extract the iso curve on
this one so this is the curve we are
going to have the decoration on I'm
going to turn into a red color so you
know what I'm talking about all right
and we don't need that long so ass can
get inside of the bezel and then we can
bowling Union together so I'm going to
use the split command with the point and
split something right in the middle or
inside of the bezel so this is the part
that we're going to do the design in
between with this line I'm going to
simply wanted to know how long is it so
the command is length and it is
2.13 4 mm making a copy and then right
here I'm going to draw a line exactly
the same length and that is the curve
it's going to represent this curve if it
is flat all right so within this curve
we need to do some Design coming into
the all view here I'm going to draw a
circle snapping into this point and let
me draw something quite small because
it's a decoration piece and then with
this piece I'm going to do the polar
array for three of them you can do more
if you like to uh minimum is two and
this is the center and I want to have
three of them and then I'll get
something like this okay so this is our
element we need to turn it into the one
piece so let me go ahead to trim
everybody right in the middle and don't
forget to join them I also like to fit
the corner while it's turning before it
turning into any solid and so I want
something quite small like
025 and then that will be our element
there with this one I need to know where
the center is so I'm going to use the
analyze and then you have this mess
property and we want to find where the
center is you see that dot there this is
the center of this area and we simply
want to moving everybody from this point
to snapping to the midpoint of that
curve there all right so now we have
this one let's go ahead to making into
the
solid and make sure both side is on and
make sure solid is on and then we got
something like
that I would like to again fit it before
we do anything so the filled edges let's
try something really small
maybe1 two and see how that works it
look like nice and we're going to do the
same thing on the other
side okay all right so now with this one
we can twist it by using the twist
command and this is the object that we
want to twist and this is the excess
from here to here and we're going to
twist maybe one two two turn and work at
something like that I think that is a
little bit too much so maybe just one
turn we're going to twist from here to
to here and go just one
turn okay that's much better uh too much
of a detail it's actually not going to
see after you polish because they will
be gone all right so now we need to have
this hopping nicely on this curve over
there so let's do a flow along curve and
we want to pick up this object there he
enter this is the base curve and the
target Curve will be this one over there
so now we can having this one over here
let's take a look on the render view
also it look like this one is stick on
the top if that work for you that's fine
and if you don't like it you do want to
make a a c you can pipe you can pipe the
center one let me show you what I mean
here for this one we can simply just
pipe it and for something about this
size and if I
bowling difference this one out of the
pipe and you can see something sitting
inside for the whole piece if that work
for you it's really up to you for what
you like anyway so uh do your own
design and kind of trick it to see what
shape work better for you after that you
can pick up this one and we just need to
do the polar array so so let's go polar
array and we want to do the number
exactly the same with the stone for 10
of them then we'll get something like
this so let's go ahead to making that
into a cylinder by extruded straight and
make sure the both side is
extruded and we have a two shape over
here let's go ahead and pick up both of
them and then we want a bowl in
difference with this guy here
so now we have something like this and
make sure that you kill it on this Stone
it is still have enough room or the cool
might stick it out in this case actually
it's a little bit too low so I'm going
to move up
everybody like
this and then we're going to do the
bowling difference those two will be
trimmed by this cylinder and and that's
safer all right to making a ring shank
is quite easy we are going to use the uh
conic Corners my favorite one and we're
going to draw something like this for
whatever size that work for you and for
this one let's move it into the quadrant
there and also at the same time I would
like to mirror to the
top snapping Center is zero and to do
something like that I do like it to uh
be taper so let me hiding this so you
can see what I'm doing
there this one I actually want them to
be taller so I'm going to go ond
scale snapping to this point to this
point and I basically want to go
taller about
that all right and uh what exactly how
you need it uh we can record history and
we can adjust it so let's use the sweep
one rail so this is a rail crosssection
one and
two and you want to make sure they all
align
perfectly and facing the same direction
let's click
enter and close the sweep and don't
forget to record a history all right so
then if we turn on everything else that
we were hiding and ideally you do not
want to have the shank is higher than
this one so this is actually perfect if
not since you recorded history you can
adjust with your curve
there all right so we need to trim the
middle section off so that's using the
bulling split this one will be split by
this one it say we break the history
that's okay we don't need a history
anymore and then uh let me hide in this
one to to show you this one is being
split but it's still there and then we
can hit enter to um to delete it and
then let's bring back this one okay
don't forget to cut the the hole in the
back to reduce the weight so let's go
ahead to just using a
cylinder and the size is just inside of
the
bezel and we want it pretty long like
this so we can trim it off off easy
we're going to do the bowling
difference this guy it's going to be
difference out on this guy all right so
don't forget to cut the stone uh hole
that we've been talking about multiple
time in many other videos so I'm not
going to repeat it here and let's take a
look on the render View and see if
everything work fine to you I hope you
enjoy the video if you're new to jury
care design I have a free mini course
specific design for a beginner where I
talk about the fundamental for stone
setting concept talk about the pron set
bezel set and how do you design custom
main proc set it's completely free the
sign up link is in the description below
hope you enjoy it thank you for watching
and I'll see you next
[Music]